as Diane finished that reading with a
flourish this is the good news of the
gospel seems like it's been 12 weeks
since we were really able to say that
without crossing our fingers all those
weeks of hard prophetic readings of
seemingly the possibly bad news of the
gospel and here we are finally at the
end of Advent after all those hard
prophetic words here we are with this
word of promise to an individual about
how God is going to do what God said we
made it as I tried this week to get my
last papers graded and close down the
semester I was troubled by my own lack
of Christmas spirit I just wasn't
feeling it this year I don't know if any
of you ever feel that way I started
making the cookies i started writing the
cards i started buying the gifts but it
just wasn't coming that warm peace on
earth god bless us everyone kind of
feeling I like that feeling that warm
cozy sweet kind Christmases baking
cookies smell kind of feeling perhaps it
was because I had a chest cold or
perhaps it was the precarious state of
the world perhaps was wondering about
our homeless friends on the first 20
degree night in New Haven but it was
also part of me that wondered is
Christmas just about sweet sentiment
because that's often the expectation I
have of myself that I should feel this
warmth this universal love and if I
don't I begin to wonder if I'm really
doing Christmas right is there something
more something more for me when the
sentiment just isn't happening so I
picked up our Advent reflections book
that many of you wrote reflections for
and I read through the pages again
wondering what I'm
might find there and there was something
there that I wasn't getting from my
internal expectations for the season it
was a direction from longing to hope and
that's what I found also in our
scriptures for the day page after page
there there was longing for change for
peace for transformation for meaning for
purpose longing for God and longing for
Christ and I realized I couldn't really
get a Christmas spirit until I could
identify what longing Christmas fulfills
in me and our world and how God does
that so I turned to our scriptures for
the day to try to reconnect Advent with
the Bible readings we hear but largely
go unnoticed in the Christmas rush these
readings that they're there but we don't
really connect them with American
Christmas there's sort of two different
worlds listen to these scriptures again
what are they talking about David is
talking about building a house for God
and this eternal line that will be
created Mary is talking about the same
thing about how this line will be
restored through history and will bring
about the Christ I love the story from
second Samuel probably because it tells
us how God responds to our longing it's
always in a way we don't expect or
understand the story is great one king
david has been finally been granted
peace after the years of conquest and is
resting in his new palace in Jerusalem
so David decides that God symbolized by
the ark should also have rest and says
I'm going to build God a house a temple
but God speaks through Nathan the
Prophet to David and says did I ask for
a house where'd you get this idea
he reminds David and Nathan about the
past God has a habit of doing that every
time God speak God's reminds you what
God has done for you in the past how God
has provided victory and a subtle place
for the people and that a temple misses
the point God's covenant is within
people and the righteousness of the
nation not in a building it's a familiar
biblical theme people shouldn't try to
speak for God or box God em I wonder if
that's maybe what I'm doing with
Christmas this God will not be told what
God should do or what God should want
this God refuses to be the God people
want him to be this God has peculiar in
particular ways but the story is not
just about conquest and hope it's not
written actually at a high point but it
speaks to us in a very different way
once you realize when it was written
this was not written when David was
riding high was written many many many
years later during the exile in
Babylonia we realized that this was
written after that great Kingdom had
been divided and conquered and its own
people scattered in this context the
story changes because it's not it's not
just about a God who won't be boxed in
it's about a nation who had built a
temple and a city and a small Empire and
a kingship and who had lost it all so
when God says I don't need a temple it's
a message of hope because the temple is
gone God didn't go away it says when the
temple was destroyed God is not in the
building but in the people and in their
hope and that hope is embodied in this
dream that keeps coming up the crowd
advent of a new king descended from
David who will bring the people out of
exile and hopelessness it seemed to
stretch
what did the promise of a line of
extinct Middle Eastern Kings have
exactly to do with my world and my
Christmas I think the language of kings
gets in the way but the hope is
universal we are living in exile hoping
that the things we value most faith
compassion justice kindness truth that
these things still matter and that they
have not been overwhelmed by the evil of
our world by the sea of anger and
selfishness and greed and callousness
and lying that we see every day just by
turning on the television as we see all
the institutions we once believed in
church and state banks business all
somehow tainted we look for hope that
there is a continuous line an invisible
church a remnant waiting for the day
when the truth will again be heard and
received and that's the same hope we
hear in the story of Mary the angel says
that the child to be born will be a king
in the line of David who will rule over
the house of Jacob forever the nation
did return from exile and a new temple
was built but a long line of oppressors
the macedonians the seleucids and
finally in Mary's time the Romans
followed the hopeful word of the angel
to marry is that finally the people will
have peace and joy the Christmas spirit
it seems is not just a sweet story about
a baby in a stable it is that but it is
the hope that God will remember God's
promises and act in history to save the
people from oppression and daft and so
we sing o come o come Emmanuel and
ransom captive Israel the mourns in
lonely exile here until the Son of God
appear it can't get much more specific
than that the people's long oppression
will end and God will appear it's not a
sentiment it's not just warmth it is a
real hope
but the same God who refused to live in
a house built by human hands fulfills
hope in unexpected ways and just as with
King David God seems to know that if
we're given a chance to exploit God for
our own ends we will of course so God
has to do God's business in unexpected
ways and unexpected places whenever the
people of Israel seem to identify their
hope with a particular person place
movement or regime God says sorry that's
not it and he says the same to us when
God finally does come it will be in the
most unlikely place with the most
ordinary people just to prove the point
Nazareth is nowhere Nazareth does not
even appear in the Hebrew Bible Nazareth
is not on anybody's map it is wink Texas
it is 10 e Minnesota and Mary is the
most ordinary unimportant person
imaginable a teenage girl from an
unknown town the hope we receive in the
season is that we should believe that
God will come to fulfill God's promises
and believe it fervently but we should
also know that this God is the god of
Isaiah 55 my thoughts are not your
thoughts and my ways are not your ways
when our hope gets to specific when we
identify with a person a project a party
or even a church we can be pretty sure
it's wrong this Advent comes at a rough
time the global economy is teetering and
yet the rich seem to get richer and more
heedless every day the food bank shelves
are empty nations are crumbling and
chaos seems near but despair is not an
option for us yes we want a leader we
want to plan we want to guarantee we are
planners after all but the only
guarantee is that God will come where we
least expect it the advent hope is that
what is most important to us will not be
lost or forgotten but we cannot dream of
the
will happen and the person represents
this best is Mary often forgotten by
Protestants out of fear that we might
sound to Catholic Mary is in many ways
the linchpin of the Christmas story for
from her response to the angel and her
song of rejoicing we know that she
fervently believes in a God who will act
to save the nation and restore God's
rule she has the story down she knows
the promises the dreams the hopes of her
people specific as can be but the
problem is that story wonderful in the
abstract has suddenly stopped on her
doorstep take all your dreams of what
might be what God might do what we might
do and suddenly it arrives and says okay
it's you it's going to happen through
you john van de laar a Methodist
minister from South Africa writes that
what is extraordinary about Mary is her
ordinary ness what is special about her
is that she is not special Christmas
happens not because she was somehow more
than human but because in a very
ordinary normal human asst she could
imagine that the same God who had
promised Israel eternal covenant that
this same God could choose her through
which to realize his help our God is not
a God who picks princesses hidden
princesses out of every little girl or
every little boy that imagines he's
Harry Potter that he will escape from
his evil family and beasts and be
selected as the one the hidden one the
great one our God is the one who goes to
the most ordinary person and says
because of your ordinary ness I choose
you because I come not for the special I
come for all
I know it's a heresy in a place like
Yale but God's love or spirit is not
focused on extraordinary people
extraordinary people are interesting but
they have one problem they're not
ordinary and since most people are
ordinary like me those extraordinary
people can't connect with them so God
takes ordinary people and by God's
Spirit helps them to do extraordinary
things we sing about the town and the
him but it might as well be about Mary
the hopes and fears of all the years are
met in thee tonight Frederick bikaner
and his wonderful paragraph about the
angel Gabriel says Gabriel came to
marrying and he told her what the child
was to be named and who he was to be and
something about the mystery that was to
come upon her he said you mustn't be
afraid Mary but as he said it he only
hoped she wouldn't notice that beneath
the great golden wings he himself was
trembling with fear to think that the
whole future of creation hung now on the
answer of a girl the mystery of
Christmas is incarnation God and
humanity meeting touching embracing
God's long twisted love story with
humanity comes down to this the hopes
and fears of all the years are met in
thee what is asked of Mary is can you
imagine incarnation and can you imagine
it now here in you and that's what
Christmas asks of us
can we imagine it now here in us there
is a place an untouched place a center
in each of us that has never been
entered a place where not only our
individual longings but the longings of
all of broken and beaten humanity meet a
place inside a place that only God can
touch if only we opened the door so one
day and youth in old age at the least
expected time we have a dream we hear a
cry for help we have an unexpected
opportunity and suddenly the broken
pieces of the puzzle all come together
to into a hole a hole that unites God's
dream and our dream Mary Ponder's but
she doesn't wait let it be for me as
your spirit tells a kingdom of peace
with no end Mary doesn't do what I was
told when something is offered I was
told to say no twice right he could
accept it on the third try an extra
helping or a gift or an opportunity Mary
doesn't do that she doesn't seem to care
what anybody thinks about her because
the story she knows is not about her
it's about being asked if you want to be
the person through whom peace joy love
and hope will finally come into creation
Mary was willing to step out of her
planned ordinary life and step into the
flow of God's grace she was willing to
hear God's message that her plans her
dreams could only really be fulfilled if
the dreams and plans of all were
realized and that is the promise of
Christmas that we will not be
extraordinary individuals but we will
step into that stream of God's grace
responding not to individual needs not
responding not to the plans that someone
imposed on me but responding to the
cries of creation throughout all of
history in Mary I found my Christmas
spirit hoping that God is not sleeping
or forgetful
that those promises of peace and justice
and healing have not expired knowing
that this God does not choose the best
or the brightest but always chooses the
least likely to show God's glory she
believed that the hopes and fears of all
the years met in her and that God had
the power to use even her and God did so
what is the real Christmas spirit it is
the longing that our exile might be over
and that our reunion might come through
the ordinary 'used of people even me
even you men